Maxime Da Silva,
l'élection européenne du 09/06, c'est 1 élection
à la proportionnelle à 1 tour.
Est-ce qu'il y a 1 vote utile ?
Oui, il y a 1 vote utile,
c'est le butin de l'Union populaire,
parce que c'est utile
euh, de voter pour l'augmentation du SMIC,
c'est utile de euh
permettre que la ligne radicale à gauche soit euh
devant et que ça puisse euh,
poser les jalons d'une alternative à Macron et Le Pen.
Euh. Pour deux-mille-vingt-sept,
c'est utile de se battre pour des députés de combat.
Et je vous parlais tout à l'heure du
euh, bilan impressionnant de nos €4 députés sortants,
c'est utile de soutenir les insomnies
qui sont aujourd'hui la voie de la paix
euh, dans cette élection.
Et enfin, c'est utile, vu l'urgence écologique
et vu euh. Les
directions politiques qui sont prises par la
Commission européenne et par le
gouvernement, qui vont à l'inverse
de ce que nous devrions faire pour le climat,
et bien il y a 1 vote utile pour les gens,
pour le peuple,
c'est celui de l'Union populaire.
Et ça se passe le neuf/06